aimer notre pays
oh merde
nous sommes tous très heureux de se voir
ici je pense que ce n'est pas tout à
fait vrai docteur voici les oies dos du
siège
je cherche simplement en savoir un peu
plus sur morgan morgan c'est notre
troisième tentative de chine notre
victoire
c'est le prochain stade d'évolution elle
a été créée par bio ingénierie à partir
de l'adn synthétique
en un mois elle marchait et parlait
en six mois c'était bien entre nos
espoirs les plus fous
j'aimerais parler de l'incident si c'est
possible
elle a piqué une crise il y avait de la
joie dans son coeur avant qu'on la
remette dans cette boîte de 100 tu un
peu triste morgan
oui tu as aimé être ici oui qu'est ce
qui te plaît ici j'aime mes amis tu
penses qu'il te traite comme une amie
est ce que tu trouves normal que des
anis enferme les uns les autres dans des
cages
que ferais tu si je préconisais que tu
ne sois pas autorisés à quitter cette
pièce et si je préconisais que tu soit
éliminé il faut arrêter ça serait pour
moi qu'est ce que tu fais
morgane ce que vous ne comprenez pas
c'est que morgane continue d'évoluer
tout le monde dans cette maison est en
danger
il faut l'éliminer 7
n'aie pas peur il
je commence à me sentir moi même
nous avons tout de suite compris que
morgane était exceptionnelle
en l'espace d'un mois elle marchait et
parlait en six mois elle était autonome
elle a dépassé tous nos espoirs les plus
fous
elle est comme une offense morgan est
une enfant elle a piqué une crise
le comportement de morgan a été très
regrettable elle apprend et on a le
droit de faire des erreurs
c'est une chose et elle n'a aucun droit
vous vous trompez vous verrez morgan
s'il te plaît malgré les déboires
actuels et hop tu arrêtes le retour sur
notre investissement sont tout à fait
remarquables
il est popularité
bonjour morgen ravi de rencontrer en
chair et en os
tu vas voir on va être très heureuse